if you've seen the Lego Batman movie
you'll know it includes not only super
well-known villains like the Joker but
also an incredible range of other
villains from the DC Comics rogues
gallery and scattered throughout the
movie there are also some cool voice
cameos you might not have taken in so in
this video I'm going to run through many
of those villains and cameos for you
quick warning there are spoilers ahead
so if you're not ready for those get out
of Gotham by tapping or clicking here to
watch my spoiler free Lego Batman movie
review by the way I'll have a great
giveaway to win a pair of Awesome Lego
Batman movie books on my Lego Batman
Easter Egg video so make sure you
subscribe and turn on your notifications
so you don't miss out ok let's start
with the villains with the Joker hired
for his dastardly attack on the Gotham
energy facility at the beginning of the
movie the first celebrity cameo is by
Conan O'Brien who voices the Riddler and
he's joined by scarecrow who masquerades
as a pizza delivery guy and is voiced by
comic actor Jason Mantzoukas Doug Benson
voices vane and does a good job sounding
very similar to Tom Hardy's take on the
character in The Dark Knight Rises
classic Batman villain two-face is
played by Billy Dee Williams who voices
iconic Star Wars character Lando
Calrissian in the first lego movie and
he also played Harvey Dent in the 1989
Batman movie in fact Williams had hoped
Harvey Dent would become two-face in the
sequel Batman Returns but the character
was dropped from that movie and when
two-face did appear in Batman Forever he
was played by Tommy Lee Jones Catwoman
who helps the villains hack into the
system is voiced by zoe kravitz who
starred in x-men first class and the
divergent series indeed crabbit actually
has some shocking prior history with the
Batman franchise specifically the Dark
Knight Rises which she would inform she
couldn't audition for a small part in
because to quote what she was told
they weren't going kerbin the comedy
folk duo Garfunkel and Oates each voice
a villain in the movie with Riki
Lindhome is poison ivy and Kate Micucci
is Clayface and rounding out the Joker's
posse of major villains is Harley Quinn
voiced by Jenny slate who was also the
voice of bellwether in Zootopia and
Gidget in the secret life of pets the
Lego Batman movie also pays homage to an
enormous stack of villains from Batman's
rogues gallery some are more familiar
like penguin who turns up in a LEGO
version of his
car that we saw in Batman Returns
there's also Killer Croc who we saw last
in the Suicide Squad movie - exclaims I
did something when he switches on the
bomb and there's mr. freeze who has a
touch of Arnold Schwarzenegger from
Batman and Robert about him when he says
no you freeze Red Hood turns up in a
blink in your missing moment during a
fight scene the official Lego site
describes this Red Hood as a mysterious
supervillain and adds that rumor
suggests he may have a secret connection
to Batman or one of his arch villains in
the comics Red Hood is an alias that has
been used by different characters -
significant ones being the Joker
and Jason Todd the lego jason todd
version of Red Hood has already appeared
in the lego video games with a
drastically different look to this Red
Hood in the Lego Batman movie and the
helmet cape and bow tie worn by the Red
Hood that appears from the Lego Batman
movie suggests that this is the Joker
Red Hood rather than Jason Todd in the
comics the Joker version of Red Hood was
an alias that the Joker used for his
criminal activities before he became the
Joker other villains who appear
on-screen very briefly include Captain
Boomerang aka digger who get kicked in
the head by Batman in the movie in the
comics he's a criminal who uses
high-tech boomerangs and we last saw him
on the big screen played by Jai Courtney
in the Suicide Squad movie
he's also man-bats who first appeared in
the comics in 1970 as Kirk Langstrom a
scientist who accidentally turned
himself into a bat man that hasn't
appeared yet in a live-action Batman
film despite being considered for
various cancels Batman projects the
closest thing so far has been the bat
creature that attacked Bruce Wayne
during his nightmare in Batman V
Superman perhaps one of the darkest
villains in the Lego Batman movie
although frankly that's a tough call his
condiment King he first appeared in
Batman the Animated Series and has often
been used for comedic effect with an
emphasis on condiment inspired puns the
character was later introduced into the
comics under the name of Mitchell Mayo
King Tut is a Batman villain that was
initially created for the 1960s Batman
TV series I was later adapted into the
comic book King Tut aka William McElroy
was an Egyptologist at Yale who
transformed into a delusional villain
when he lost his mind
after being hit on the head during a
student riot
egghead who turns up in the Lego Batman
movie egging the bat-signal is another
villain who appeared in the 1960s Batman
TV series where he was played by Vincent
Price Helen Ross first appeared in
Batman issue 63 where he set himself up
as the opposite of Batman helping
Gotham's criminal underworld killer loss
also had a fake identity as a rich guy
called Cameron van Cleer
and similar to that money had a moss
'mobile as well as a moss signal that
criminals used to call him kite man aka
Charles Brown in the comics is said to
be partly inspired by the peanuts
character Charlie Brown who struggles to
fly a kite kite man first appeared in
1960 in Batman issue 133 and as you can
guess he used kite base weapons to fight
Batman gentlemen ghost is a supernatural
villain in the comics who is created
when the thief Jim Craddock was hanged
by the gunslinger Nighthawk polka-dot
man is a Batman villain who in the
comics can transform the colored dots on
his trick now costume into various
weapons
Catman first appeared in Detective
Comics in 1963 and modeled his look on a
combo of Batman and Catwoman more
chariot is based on the comic book
villain Harriet Pratt aka March Hare who
along with Tweedledum Tweedledee and the
Mad Hatter was part of the window line
gang the villainous zebra man has
appeared in several different versions
in the comics in his first incarnation
he invented a machine that charged his
body with energy which gave him his
powers and strike he also wore a special
belt to control his body's powerful
diamagnetic force the eraser is a
villain whose costume includes a mask
for the giant eraser on top and suitably
enough he hires himself out to criminals
to raise evidence left at crime scenes
Orca is the scientist dr. grace fallan
who experimented with spinal cord
regeneration after she was paralyzed
she transformed into an orca human
hybrid after experimenting with Orca
tissue the comic book version of
tarantula who appears in the movie is
the former FBI agent catalina Flores who
takes the law into her own hands to deal
with corrupt police officers and
criminals clock King was a foe of Green
Arrow in the comics and used his clock
and time-based skills to turn to crime
as a way to support his sister when he
was mistakenly diagnosed with a terminal
in
on earth and calendar man is a date
obsessed villain whose crimes relate to
specific dates and holidays now the Lego
Batman movie doesn't restrict itself to
villains and DC Comics TV shows or
movies in fact the Phantom Zone is home
to a number of tracks normandy seed
berlin comedian Eddie Izzard provides
the voice of Voldemort
delivering some great lines like stop
moving around muggles and he also uses a
levitation charm Wingardium Leviosa
several times in the movie
I wonder what ray Fiennes who plays
Alfred in this film and Voldemort life
in the Harry Potter movies sort of Eddie
is our take on the character Jemaine
Clement Elam heard recently as a rather
shiny crab Tama Toa in Moana delivers a
comedic animated version of Sauron from
The Lord of the Rings the iconic ape
King Kong also appears in his voiced by
Seth Green Ellie Kemper who you might
know as the unbreakable kimmy schmitt
or as Aaron from the office slender
voice - Phyllis the brightly coloured
brick who served as a gatekeeper to the
Phantom Zone there's also a bunch of
other cool villains including dr. Hughes
Daleks a Velociraptor from Jurassic Park
Jaws Medusa the gremlins Dracula Agent
Smith from the matrix and the Wicked
Witch of the West also makes an
appearance with her flying monkeys so
hilarious Justice League anniversary
party scene also brings back some
characters and voices from the first
lego movie
Channing Tatum returns as a voice of
Superman and Jonah Hill and Adam Devine
a back of Green Lantern and the flash
respectively other Justice League
members at the party include Wonder
Woman Aquaman cyborg Martian Manhunter
who jokingly dubs himself Martian don't
hunter green arrow Black Canary Hawkman
and Hawkgirl the Wender twins and gleek
black Vulcan Apache chief El Dorado and
wonder dog and in Gotham City there are
a few more celebrity cameos singdam
Mariah Carey is a voice of Myr McCaskill
the retiring Commissioner Jim Gordon is
played by pretty woman Hector Elizondo
Chris Hardwick of Nerdist train with one
of the reporters quitting Barbara Gordon
after the Joker surrenders and the Lego
Batman movie director Chris McKay is
pilot bill who argues with the Joker
about why Batman will foil his evil
plans now did you have a favorite cameo
in the movie and if there's a Lego
Batman sequel few would you like to see
have more screen time let me know
in the comments below and if you enjoyed
this I really appreciate if you hit the
thumbs up button share and subscribe you
can also tap or click here for more of
my videos including all the best Easter
eggs from the Lego Batman movie thanks
for watching and see you next time you'd
be going movie lovers